bonjour à tous Je me prénomme just space
je suis créateur de contenu sur les
réseaux sociaux et aujourd'hui il sera
question donc d'innovation plus
précisément sur la thématique du
marketing d’influence est-ce que vous
savez ce que c'est le marketing
d'influence
non ok le marketing d’influence c'est un
tout nouveau type de marketing qui va
s'appuyer sur des leaders d'opinion des
influenceurs afin de mettre en avant
promouvoir des objets des services
malheureusement
cette notion est un petit peu flouée ces
derniers temps la notion d'influenceurs
par le mot influe voleur des leaders
d'opinion des influenceurs qui vont vous
proposer des produits souvent issus du
dropshipping le dropshipping c'est
lorsque vous achetez sur un site et que
le fournisseur en question passe par un
fournisseur tierce donc il ne gère ni
les stocks ni les envoie de commande des
produits donc issus du dropshipping que
vous allez jamais recevoir et souvent
vendu à des prix beaucoup plus élevés
ainsi pour
continuer dans cette explication il est
important pour moi de différencier les
influenceurs des créateurs de contenu
les créateurs de contenu quant à eux se
sont souvent des personnes qui sont
passionnées qui vont mettre en place
leurs idées souvent sous forme de vidéo
et vous les proposez sur les plateformes
les plus populaires
je pense que je fais partie de ceux-là
réfléchir tester mettre en place tenter
l'innovation ça fait partie de moi
malheureusement subsiste quelques
problématiques notamment une principale
à laquelle j'ai dû faire face à savoir
quels sont les limites finalement de
l'innovation sur un marché qui ne serait
pas encore mature
alors avant d'aller plus loin je vais
vous faire un petit
rappel je vais vous raconter un petit
peu mon histoire
je grandis avec un père gamer toutes les
consoles à la maison je suis déjà au top
de l'innovation finalement et je me
rappelle des week-ends passer
entièrement avec lui sur la console de
jeux malheureusement ces moments
précieux avec lui vont être écourtés
très rapidement dès l'arrivée de ma
petite sœur
qui va être suivi un an plus tard par
l'arrivée de mon petit frère en toute
honnêteté c'est tout mon monde qui va
chambouler je n'aurai plus le même temps
de jeu avec mon père le même temps tout
court finalement et je vais me sentir
vraiment très seul je vais continuer à
grandir toujours avec les jeux vidéo et
même secrètement peut-être rêvé d'en
faire mon métier mais c'est réellement
l'adolescence en 2008 soit 10 ans après
Windows 98 c'est incroyable
que je vais avoir une révélation je vais
te bloquer sur un jeu et je ne vais pas
trouver la solution pas même mon père
gamer va pouvoir me venir en aide c'est
donc à ce moment là que je vais
innocemment Google liser le nom du jeu
ainsi que le niveau sur lequel je suis
bloqué et c'est là que la magie va
opérer je vais découvrir YouTube une
plateforme qui permet le partage de
vidéo libre
le partage de contenu que l'on souhaite
donc je vais découvrir des personnes qui
partagent des moments de vie des moments
de joie des anniversaires des baptêmes
et je veux aussi découvrir des personnes
des créateurs de contenu qui partagent
leur meilleure partie sur certains jeux
et je vais donc trouver la solution à
mon jeu et c'est à ce moment que mes
sens vont s'éveiller très rapidement je
lui décider pardon de moi-même devenir
youtubeur
et
je rigole déjà le tout premier contenu
sur lequel je vais me concentrer ça sera
sur la thématique des jeux vidéo et pour
vous faire court sur Pokémon
voilà donc c'était ma passion avant je
n'ai aucune honte à le dire j'étais un
grand fan de Pokémon et pour me défendre
le but du jeu ce n'était pas juste
d'attraper Pikachu il y avait de la
stratégie et autres
comme vous avez pu le voir j'ai un petit
peu la bougeotte donc on va faire une
avance rapide sur 2012 nous sommes en
2012 ça fait trois ans que je produis du
contenu sur Pokémon et bien évidemment
le jeu m'a saoulé je n'en peux plus et
je me rends compte finalement que je
tourne en rond dessus et surtout déjà à
cette époque je me rends compte que
finalement si je veux étendre ma
communauté je ne pourrai pas le faire
avec ce jeu là
dans le même temps internet change
internet évolue on assiste à l'arrivée
des réseaux sociaux tels que Facebook
snapchat Instagram
il devient même intéressant du coup pour
nous qui sommes créateurs de s'insérer
sur ces plateformes là
l'intérêt pour moi de produire du
contenu sur un des jeux les plus
populaires du moment sera encore plus
présent quand mon frère va me faire
découvrir Call of Duty
est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui vont jouer
à Call of Duty lever la main s'il vous
plaît ah voilà
Call of Duty fort de sa popularité je
vais constater que sur sur youtube il
existe de nombreux créateurs qui
proposent du contenu sur Call of Duty
pour ma part la prise en main du jeu
sera rapide le jeu me plaît et
excusez-moi pour toutes les personnes
qui n'ont pas levé la main Call of Duty
c'est un jeu de guerre où le but c'est
d'éliminer d'éliminer l'ennemi en équipe
tout simplement
du coup je vais avoir l'envie de
proposer du contenu sur ce jeu
finalement qui répond à toutes mes
attentes la popularité et la possibilité
pour moi de produire du contenu et pour
ce faire je vais donc faire une analyse
du marché constater de ce qui se fait
déjà en fait sur la plateforme et après
mon analyse je vais me rendre compte
finalement que la plupart des créateurs
proposent la même chose il partage leur
meilleur parti nous explique comment
arriver d'un point 1 point B rapidement
qui est l'arme utilisée sur
les cartes en question mais finalement
jamais d'information sur le créateur en
question jamais d'informations sur sa
personnalité jamais d'informations sur
ses habitudes ce qu'il aime vraiment
et c'est donc à ce moment là que je vais
essayer d'innover
finalement qu'est-ce que l'innovation je
vais essayer de vous donner ma
définition pour moi l'innovation il y a
une part de créativité la créativité ça
va être l'ensemble des idées qu'on peut
qu'on peut avoir et qu'on va essayer de
mettre en place l'innovation ça va être
la validation de nos idées qui après
vérification justement
on constate on constatera un changement
de mode de consommation de la cible
et donc mon objectif sera le suivant
innover le marché de Call of Duty sur
Youtube alors pour procéder je vais tout
simplement faire comme tous les autres
moi aussi je vais partager mes
meilleures parties parce que j'en étais
capable mais la différence se situera
dans ce que je raconterai dans les
vidéos
et très rapidement j'ai compris que les
personnes qui regardaient les vidéos
s'attacher aux personnalités et c'est
comme ça que mon tout premier concept
sur Youtube naîtra les story life les
story life
pour traduire en français c'est
l'histoire de ma vie les story life vont
représenter une cinquantaine d'épisodes
sur deux ans ou à chaque vidéo je
raconterai mais plus belles anecdotes le
premier râteau que je me suis pris la
fois où j'ai passé mon bac
la faux j'ai raté mon permis et autres
et finalement ce concept il va me
permettre d'atteindre les 100 000
abonnés rapidement et on va se rendre
compte finalement que c'est le fait de
s'attacher à la personnalité du créateur
se rendre compte que les personnes qui
regardent le contenu vidéo peuvent elles
aussi vivent la même chose ou être
peuvent s'assimiler finalement et c'est
comme cela que je vais réussir à
constituer ma toute première vraie
communauté
ce qui va être intéressant aussi de
constater avec ce projet c'est qu'il y
aura un avant après
j'aurais à mon sens réussi une certaine
forme d'innovation puisque
ah voilà on constatera que quelques
années plus tard de nombreux youtubeurs
reprendront le concept l'adapterons
alors communauté
et finalement
raconteront leurs anecdotes en vidéo
voici quelques exemples
on va faire une petite avance rapide une
nouvelle fois comme vous le voyez j'ai
vraiment la bougeotte je bouge de
partout on est en 2014 et une nouvelle
fois je suis fatigué de Call of Duty le
jeu ne m'intéresse plus à mon sens j'ai
donné tout ce que je pouvais donner j'ai
apporté ma pierre à l'édifice et donc
j'ai un j'ai l'impression qu'il me faut
un nouveau défi et ça ce moment là que
effectivement mon amour pour le foot
grandissait je suis un grand fervent
supporter du PSG et j'espère que je ne
suis pas le seul dans la salle
ouais bizarre
allez Paris
donc je vais m'orienter vers FIFA le jeu
de jeu de foot numéro 1 en terme de
simulation
ma recette va être la même et je vais
mettre en avant ma personnalité au
détriment de juste ce qu'il se passe
dans le jeu donc finalement le jeu sera
toujours pour moi un support un prétexte
finalement me permettant de produire des
vidéos mais ce qui sera intéressant
c'est ce que je raconterai dedans
pour être tout à fait honnête avec vous
ce jeu FIFA
ce jeu FIFA va me permettre de passer un
cap réel je vais passer de 100.000
abonnés à 400000 abonnés ça va être
aussi le moment où je vais devoir
commencer à me professionnaliser parce
qu'à cette époque les marques commença à
nous approcher qui dit Marc dit
opération commerciale qui dit opération
commerciale dit
émission de facture qui dit émissions de
facture il faut un statut bref vous avez
compris
dans le même temps aussi comme je vous
ai dit auparavant j'étais sur les
réseaux sociaux Facebook snapchat
Instagram Twitter et j'ai oublié de vous
mettre en détail c'est vrai que mes
études mon Master digital marketing que
je préparais à l'époque m'a beaucoup
aidé dans ça
et qui dit études c'est vrai qu'au début
j'ai parlé de mes parents enfin de mon
père plutôt de façon très positive mais
les études c'est très important les jeux
vidéo aussi mais les études je crois que
c'est encore plus important du coup
quand je préparé mon Master digital
marketing
j'ai dû faire un choix à un moment donné
c'est à dire mettre de côté ma chaîne
même si ça m'a fait beaucoup de mal mais
j'étais obligé de le faire parce que mes
parents
m'obligez pas forcément mais le
recommander gentiment du coup j'ai
préparé mon Master digital marketing et
j'ai fait en sorte d'avoir rapidement
mon diplôme nous sommes du coup en 2017
le master en poche je pense délivré mais
je me suis trompé lorsque j'ai eu mon
Master ma mère m'a obligé à valoriser le
diplôme en ayant une première expérience
en entreprise chose que je vais faire de
toute façon j'ai pas le choix
et donc je vais obtenir un premier
expérience en tant que consultant en
transformation numérique ne me posez pas
de questions je ne peux pas vous
expliquer réellement ce que c'est
je voudrais juste remercier un homme qui
a beaucoup compté pour moi et qui m'a
donné beaucoup de confiance monsieur
Layani qui m'a embauché sur profil et
qui lors de l'entretien m'a posé des
questions
très pertinentes à savoir quels étaient
mes motivations à rejoindre l'entreprise
j'ai été honnête avec lui je lui ai dit
que j'en avais pas vraiment c'était mes
parents qui m'obliger
et ce qui est incroyable c'est que en
réalité il faut être honnête parce que
j'étais embauché j'étais embauché en
étant honnête ce qui va être intéressant
de constater c'est que
durant cette période où je me focalisais
beaucoup plus sur le professionnel je
n'avais plus le même temps je n'avais
plus le même temps à passer sur les jeux
vidéos je ne pouvais plus jouer autant à
FIFA et je dois vous dire la vérité mon
intérêt aussi pour les jeux vidéo
diminué alors le peu de temps qu'il me
restait je le consacrer à ma passion
première qui est la musique j'ai une
grande passion pour le rap pour la
culture urbaine et donc le peu de temps
que j'avais je m'amusais à proposer des
vidéos
sur des analyses de rap voilà des
analyses d'album de rap pardon
j'analysais les albums je donnais mon
avis
parfois je me faisais tapé dessus parce
que les gens n'étaient pas d'accord mais
en tout cas c'était une façon pour moi
de pouvoir extérioriser peut-être la
frustration la frustration que j'avais
de ne pas pouvoir être aussi régulier
qu'avant mais ça me permettait d'être
actif et surtout de proposer encore une
fois quelque chose de nouveau
lorsque je vais intégrer cette
entreprise comme je vous ai dit j'ai un
petit peu abusé de la gentillesse du
patron
et donc j'ai surtout passé mon temps à
mettre en place des formations
réseaux sociaux à l'encontre des cadres
seniors qui découvrait les réseaux
sociaux les hashtags les 140 caractères
à l'époque de Twitter
mais surtout penser un nouveau format
je pense que vous l'aurez compris
l'innovation c'est quelque chose qui m'a
toujours animé que je sois actif ou pas
et c'est donc à cette période que je
commence à m'intéresser à Jimmy kimmels
Jimmy Fallon est-ce que vous connaissez
c'est c'est présentateur que je cite
Jimmy Kim et les Jimmy Fallon ce sont
des présentateurs de talk show aux
États-Unis qui arrive à mettre en avant
le divertissement comme personne ils ont
une façon de présenter les choses de
séquencer leurs interviews de d'accès
leur contenu sur la personnalité de
l'artiste c'est quelque chose que j'ai
toujours aimé et c'est quelque chose que
je vais essayer de mettre en place par
moi-même
durant cette période du coup quand je
travaillais la majeure partie du temps
de passer à penser ce nouveau concept et
une fois que le nouveau concept sera
pensé de la même façon que j'ai fait
pour Call of Duty que j'ai fait pour
FIFA je vais analyser le marché des
interviews dans le rap en France et je
vais me rendre compte encore une fois
que la plupart font la même chose les
interviews sont monotones les interviews
sont longues on s'intéresse qu'à ce que
l'artiste a à vendre
et finalement on s'ennuie tout
simplement donc je me dis que j'ai ma
carte à jouer
j'ai ma carte à jouer avec un concept
qui va s'appeler l'open space qui va
émettre la promesse à la personne qui la
regarde de voir une interview dynamique
c'est quand c'est et surtout axé sur la
personnalité de l'artiste
les deux premiers épisodes que je
produirai seront autofinancés par mes
soins et très rapidement grâce au calcul
vu qu'on a pu faire je vais être
approché par une grosse entreprise de
production télé je ne peux pas la citer
cette entreprise va me proposer un
système de co-production est-ce que vous
savez ce que c'est la coproduction non
la coproduction en fait c'est moi j'ai
mon projet je dois léguer 50%
contre un studio dans lequel je pourrais
donc faire mes vidéos mais aussi une
équipe de tournage ce qui est importante
quand même avec du matériel et
l'objectif de pouvoir s'affilier à des
marques des sponsors pourquoi parce que
ça coûte de produire un épisode donc
l'idée de sa fille avec une marque c'est
de pouvoir couvrir les frais de
production et pourquoi pas dégager du
bénéfice
du coup avec cette entreprise cette
vidéo vont être produites pour un total
de 4 millions de vues le succès sera au
rendez-vous le succès sera tel que
l'année qui suit je serai racheté à 50%
bien sûr
par cette fois-ci le leader de la
production digitale
ensemble nous ferons cette saison
lorsque j'ai été racheté par cette
entreprise la promesse elle était
incroyable
tu auras un meilleur studio tu auras une
meilleure équipe et surtout
on connaît tout le monde donc ne
t'inquiète pas les marques seront au
rendez-vous et on saura sponsorisé
pour vous faire court la collaboration
avec cette entreprise n'a pas été
fructueuse
finalement lorsque vous regardez les
statistiques des vidéos qui sont devant
vous
elles sont plutôt bonnes qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez
les stades sont plutôt bonnes on arrive
à avoir une diversité au niveau des
invités malheureusement il y avait un
point essentiel qui faisait que ça ne
fonctionnait pas avec ma collaboration
nous avons jamais réussi à trouver un
sponsor nous permettant de couvrir nos
frais de production jamais
et je dois vous avouer quelque chose à
cette époque j'étais dans la dans la
compréhension totale
comment expliquer qu'un concept qui
fonctionne qui a l'air plutôt innovant
qui parle un public ne rencontrent pas
de succès auprès des marques
et aucune d'elle ne souhaite finalement
s'y affilier
bah j'ai toujours pas la réponse
j'ai la réponse je rigole finalement
à cette époque je vais tronger par la
frustration là je vais rentrer dans du
un peu plus personnel je vais tronger
par la frustration ce qui va me pousser
à me mettre de côté à prendre du temps
finalement et analyser le marché
lorsque on regarde bien durant l'année
2015-2016 je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez mais il y a eu une énorme
transformation dans le paysage musical
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il y a eu
l'arrivée du streaming l'arrivée des
plateformes de streaming tels que Apple
music Spotify Deezer
l'arrivée du streaming en France a fait
en sorte que le rap
devient à ce jour la musique le genre
musical le plus écouté en France
selon moi c'est grâce au streaming pas
que mais le streaming a beaucoup
contribué à cela
l'époque où je me suis mis en retrait
aura duré trois ans durant cette époque
comme je vous ai dit la musique a changé
le rap a évolué
et durant cette période de retrait j'ai
pu constater que les graines qu'on avait
plantées avec ce concept
poussé chez la concurrence
et après analyse on a pu constater que
la plupart de nos concurrents ont adapté
leur format des formats beaucoup plus
courts des formats beaucoup plus
séquences des formats qui seraient axés
sur la personnalité de l'artiste
alors finalement lorsque je préparais
cette présentation
je me suis fait la réflexion suivante
si je pouvais réécrire l'histoire je le
referai pas les mêmes choses
c'était mon égo qui avait fait en sorte
que je vais mettre en retrait j'étais
clairement touché et j'acceptais pas la
défaite je n'ai jamais accepté la
défaite finalement
mais j'aurais investi mon argent dans ma
production j'aurais cru en idée
et j'aurais tout fait finalement pour
que le projet
qui est ici présent devant vous soit
prêt lorsque le marché serait prêt
à contrario ce que j'ai fait c'est que
je me suis mis en retrait et j'ai vu les
autres continuer réadapter leur format
et finalement être présent lorsque les
marques seraient prêtes
alors
si j'ai bien
si j'ai bien retenu quelque chose de
cette aventure
c'est que si vous êtes dans la même
situation si vous avez une idée si vous
avez envie de la partager avec vos amis
et que lorsque vous la partagez personne
ne la comprend mais que vous êtes sûr de
vous que vous la travaillez que vous
avez confiance en vous
n'abandonnez pas parce que vous êtes
peut-être à l'aube à l'aube de quelque
chose de nouveau
je conclurai en disant que sur le marché
de l'influence il est totalement
possible
d'exister en étant créatif mais
finalement ce qui marqueront l'histoire
seront les plus innovants merci beaucoup